يتعهد بمواصله الدعم اوكرانيا
باتريوت بالاضافه المهمه لبنى
ردنا على الاعدامات في ايران واشنطن تفرض
عقوبات جديده ضد المدعي العام وقاده في
الحرس الثوري
والاتحاد الاوروبيه
ضد الانسانيه وطالبان تتحدى
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ايباي
وقال الرئيس الاوكرانيه على خلال المؤتمر
صحفيه مشترك مع الرئيس الامريكي جويده في
البيت الابيض ان الحصول كيف على انظمه
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي سيعزز بقوه قدراتها
الدفاعيه معتدل ان الامر يشكل خطوه مهمه
للغايه لخلق مجال جوي امن لاوكرانيا
التاريخيه الى واشنطن وهي الاولى لها الى
الخارج منذ بدء المعارك في بلاده على ان
السلام العادل لا ينطوي على اي مساومه على
وحده اراضي اوكرانيا
لن تكونوا ابدا لوحدكم واخيرا الى انه
واثق من ان التحالف الغربي سيظل موحدا
وراءه اوكرانيا
ليوقف ما وصفها بالحرب الوحشيه في
اوكرانيا
دكتور مجنون
استمرار الشعب الاوكراني شجاع في الدفاع
عن بلاده ضد العدوان الروسي طالما استغرق
الامر ذلك
رئيس السلام العادل
فيما يتعلقوا بسياده بلدي وحريته وسلامته
الاقليميه
زوج دواء
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها وخاصه الدفاع
الجوي ولهذا سبب سانه يزود اوكرانيا
ببطاريه صواريخ باتريوت
رجلين سعودي
مصيبه مسؤولاني كبيران
مولوصيا في قصف فندق بمدينه
روسي لكن اصابته لا تهدد حياته اما
المصابه
تم تسريبها اليهم
رئيس روسي وضع سلاح روسي النوويه على
الطاوله بتطوير وزياده اسلحه
بلاده العسكريه للعام القادم
وتركت ان تجهيز القوات النوويه مدعومه بما
يسمى الثالوث النووي وصل الى واحد وتسعين
بالمئه خطه بدات براي او بدات براي خبراء
وكانها اعلان جديد لسباق نحو التسلحين
والاستعدادات النوويه ما يمثل ضمانا
لسياده روسيا ووحده اراضيها وبشكل عام
الردع النووي والتوازن النووي في العالم
وقد تم تجهيز القوات النوويه بنسبه 91
بالمئه وايضا تم تزويد قواتنا بمنظومه
للمره الاولى بمنظومه الصواريخ العابره
الرئيس الروسيك قال ايضا ان استخدام
المسيارات اصبح امرا واقعا واكدان انه يجب
العمل على انتاج المسورات الجويه
والبحريه باحدث المواصفات
وخبره استخدام المسيارات يجب ان تكون لدى
كل مجند وهذا يجب تنفيذه في القريب العاجل
لابد من انتاج المسيررات الجويه والبحريه
باحدث المواصفات القتاليه
[موسيقى]
اعرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات
جديده ضد ايران وتشمل هذه الحزمه ثلاثه من
قاده الحرس الثوري والنسيج المسؤولين عن
القمع الاحتجاجات خاصه في كردستان ايران
اضافه الى المدعي العام في طهران محمد
منتظر بسبب محاكمات المحتاجين
من جهه هكذا الخارج
ستواصل دعم الايرانيين في مواجهه عمليات
القمر التي يمارسها النظام ضد المحتجين
باضافه الى حشد الاجماع الدوري
الايراني
قاسيه ضد المتظاهرين بينها عقوبه الاعدام
بعد محاكمات سوريه
بالوقف الفوري لعمليات القمر والاستماع
الى مطالب المحتاجين
قمر احتجاجات في اورانج على طهران عرضه
لسيل وتواصل من الانتقادات والتمديدات اخر
تهامه
الى قوات الامن الايرانيه باستخدام القوه
المفرطه غير القانونيه والمفضيه للموت ضد
المتظاهرين في مدينه سلندر وضعت المنظمه
الامم المتحده لتقص الحقائق بشان ايران
للتحقيق في هذه الانتهاكات التي وصفتها
بالجسيمه
على ممارسه السلطات الايرانيه
ضد المتظاهرين في سندد منذ سبتمبر
وماما حمله القمع عبد المحتجون في ايران
الى تغيير استراتيجيه التظاهر من النهار
الى الليل حيث ماتوا يركزون على الفترات
المسائيه للخروج باحتجاجات تملا الشوارع
كما هو الحال في العاصمه طهران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
بعد مفاوضات صعبه
في اسرائيل
اهلا بكم من جديد يعتبر الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان قرار منع النساء من التعليم في
افغانستان يمثلوا جريمه ضد الانسانيه كمال
الاوروبي بالاضافه الى دول اخرى بشده
قرارات طالبان الاخيره بحضر الفتيات من
الجامعه
عزيزه ابدا لي طالبه جامعيه تدرس في كليه
الطب منعتها طالبان من الذهاب الى الجامعه
تقول ان طموحاتها قد ذهبت ادراج الرياح
كما ذهب الطموحات زميلاتها
الان من عدنان
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي امام الفتيات
الافغانيات لنحو 16 شهرا ما اثار انتقادات
داخليه لم تؤدي الى نتائج ملمسه
ليس لدينا خيار اخر لمواصله الدراسه داخل
البلاد فاذا اردنا الدراسه علينا المغادره
للخارج
[موسيقى]
اثار ادانات دوليه
على حركه طالبان للتراجع عنه طالب ان تبرر
قرارها بانها تنشغل بالب
ث فيما الفتيات الافغانيات غير مقتنعات
بهذه التمريرات لان طالبان على سده الحكم
منظر نحو 16 شهرا وكان يجب عليها ان تتغلب
على هذه المشاكل ايا كانت عبدو نادر
العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
وفي بيان الخارجيه السعوديه عربه المملكه
عن استغرابها وسفها لقرار حكومه تصريف
الاعمال الافغانيه بمنع الفتيات من حق
التعليم الجامعي وذكر البيان السعوديه
تدعو حكومه تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه
للتراجع عن قرار منع الفتيات من حق
التعليم كما تعتبر الرياض او تعتبر الرياض
ان القرار يتنافى مع اعطاء المراه حقوق
وفي لقاء مع العربيه
في حقوق المراه وتعليم سوداب بياني بازاله
السعوديه لمنع الفتيات من التعليم في
افغانستان مطالبه دول العالم الاسلامي
باتخذه مواقف مماثله والضغط على السلطات
والوقوف مع النساء اللاتي يطالبن بابسط
حقوقهم
بقرار السعوديه بهذه الادانه واطالب باقي
الدول الاسلاميه ودول العالم ان تتخذ نفس
الموقف لان هذا البلد يحتاج الى وقفه
ونساء افغانستان لسنا بمعزل عن باقي دول
العالم الاسلامي التي يسمح فيها بتعليم
الفتيات فلماذا يتم منع النساء والفتيات
الافغانيه نحن نطالب بالمزيد من الضغط على
السلطات والوقوف مع هؤلاء النساء التي
يطالبنا بابسط حقوقهم ويتم اسكاتهم
اصواتهم لكنهن مستمرات في المطالبه
بحقوقهن والمشروعه وهذه من ابسط حقوق
الانسان وحقوق النساء بكافه الشرائع
والقوانين الدوليه
بتدمير مستقبل هذا البلد بحضر تعليم
الجامعي على النساء وشره وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لينا بيربوط الى ان الطالب
ربما تحاول جعل النساء غير مرئيات لكنها
لن تنجح مضيفه ان العالم يراقب ما يحدث في
افغانستان
قال وزير القوات المسلحه البريطانيه في
لقاء خاص مع العربيه
الذي يعمل في المنطقه سيستمر
في اليمن
توقع هناك الكثير من الاساليب المبتكره
لجمع الادله الاستخباراتيه واساليب
المراقبه من اجل خفض احتماليه ايصال
الاسلحه ووقف كل السفن بريطانيا
لتقديم عمل افضل لعرقله وصول هذه الشحنات
الى الحوثيين
واضافه هي في ان هناك محاولات كثيره
للتعارف بين بريطانيا والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه مشيرا الى ان لبلاده والرياض
رؤيه المشتركه لامن المنطقه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه عملنا على
اشياء كثيره عبر سنوات طويله اخرى
الجديده التي نسائيه اليها انها رؤيه
المشتركه لامن المنطقه ومتطلبتها وكيف
بامكان السعوديه وبريطانيا العمل من اجل
تحقيقها
توصل الى الاتفاق لتشكيل حكومه جديده بعد
مفاوضات صعبه استمرت اسابيع سوف تتولى
الحكومه الجديده التي يتعين على نت ياهو
الان ان يقدمها في حضون اسبوع السلطه بعد
عام شهد اسوا مستويات للعنف الضفه الغربيه
150 فلسطينيه واكثر من عشرين اسرائيلي
وجهها 30 دائما من اليمين الاسرائيلي
رساله الى الاتحاد الاوروبي طلبوا فيها
عدم تدخلي في ما وصفوها بشؤون الاسرائيليه
في عقاب الكشف عن وثيقه سريه تتضمن خطه
اوروبيه لدعم سياسي واقتصادي وقانوني
متكامل للفلسطينيين في مطالبه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليه
الكشف عن اعداد الاتحاد الاوروبي وثيقه
سريه تتضمن خطه لمساعده الفلسطينيين
سياسيا وقانونيا واقتصاديا على بسط
سيطراتهم على المناطق المصنفه جيم التي
تشكل 60% من الضفه الغربيه المحتله قبل
بغضب الاسرائيلي وترحيب فلسطيني نحن
نتحدثنا مع كل دول العالم حول انه لا يمكن
القبول بان يبقى الاحتلال يحاول منافع
الفلسطيني
وبالتالي يعني العديد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المصنفه تحت هذا البنت تحاول
حكومه الاحتلال السيطره عليها وبناء
وتوسيع المستعمرات الاسطانيه الوثيقه
الواقعه في ست صفحات تتحدث عن قيام
الاتحاد الاوروبي بترسيم خارطه للاراضي في
مناطق جيم والعمل قانونيه على اثبات
ملكيتها الفلسطينيه
ومراقبه النشاط الاثريه الاسرائيلي لانه
احدى ادوات فرض السيطره الاسرائيليه
والعمل من خلال مشاريع قانوني على دمج
مناطق جيم مع مناطق الف تحت سياده
الفلسطينيه وبال خاضعه لسيطره المدنيه
الفلسطينيه
فيما اعلى نوع وزير الماليه والوزير في
وزاره الدفاع مدرج انه سيطلق فور تسلمه
المنصب حمله لهدم البناء الفلسطيني في
مناطق جيم ويعمل على ضم الضفه لاسرائيل
هذه هي العلامه الاولى لما ينتظرنا من
توتر ومواجه بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه
العتيده مع الدعم الاوروبي والامريكي
للفلسطينيين في منطقه تاسيس في الضفه
الغربيه
اسرائيل ترفض تقليديا اي دور سياسي
لاوروبا في عمليه التسويه وتصر على انفراد
واشنطن في ادارتها رغم انها لم تعد قائمه
منذ سنوات لا تخفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه المتطرفه وشيكه الولاده انها
ستعمل على ضم الضفه الغربيه المحتله
لاسرائيل وانهاء حل الدولتين على الارض
ويبدو ان العلاقه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
المتفجره الطبيعه ستظل تدور في فلك تعقيد
والتصعيد زياد حلبي العربيه الضفه الغربيه
المحتله
مع غياب قرون سعاده مواسم الاحتفالات
رغمقها خلال عام 20 22 في لبنان من
المتوقع ان يدخل لبنان خلال شهر واحد 700
الف زائر معظمهم من المغتربين
الماضيه
وسط المدينه
تعدت لتضيء لياليه
من الزهور
اما القرى الميلاد واصواته فعادت لتنتشر
في اكثر من منطقه وان كانت بمبادره خاصه
[موسيقى]
مثل ما كنا عم نقول قبل انه القطاع الخاص
هو يلي امل هالبلاد مزبوط ما في غير قطاع
الخاص هو راح يرجع يقوم بها البلد
شركه طيران فوق 600 الف رح يجي على لبنان
هذا الشهر العرب
موسم جديد من المواسم السياحيه يعمل خلاله
اللبنانيون خيرا مع رفع عدد رحلات الطيران
اعلنت وزاره السياحه ان ايرادات الموسم
الصيفي لعام 2022 تجاوزت السته مليار
دولار لكن هذا الرقم لم يؤدي الى تحسين
عجله الاقتصاد خاصه ان المستفيدين فضلوا
ابقاء هذه الاموال داخل المنازل
يؤكد كارلوس صاحبه احد المطاعم النعامه
2022 كان الافضل منذ بدء الازمه لكنه
حفاوه المواسم السياحيه لم تلغي ازمه
الثقه فيرفض كارلوس كغيره من اللبنانيين
اذاعه ما يتبقى من ارباح داخل المصارف
بنخبيهم على المصاري وعلى هذا لانه يعني
الازمه فواتتنا بمشكل كثير كبير ومشغوله
تقبض الاكتريه كشته تقدر انت بالنهايه
انه ما بيقدروا يعيشوا من وراء الباب
لكن هذه الاموال تحفظوا في المنازل يستمتع
اللبنانيون باعيادهم بعيدا عن المصارف
اغنيه تيم العربيه بيروت
يلتقي اليوم فريق مانشستر سيتي وليفربول
في دوري 16 لمسابقه كاس الرابطه
الانجليزيه
من يناير
نجح الهلال في التاهل الى ربع نهائي
مسابقه كاس الملك بالسعوديه بعد فوزه على
ضيفه الاتفاق باربعه اهداف
وبلغ النصره ربع نهائي كاس الملك بفوزه
على العداله بهدفين دون رد في المباراه
التي جرت في العاصمه الرياض
بدوره تتاهل ابهي الى ربع نهائي المسابقه
بعد فوزه على ضيفه التعاون باربعه اهداف
لثلاثه
وتستكمل مباريات اليوم باجراء ثلاث
مباريات حيث يستضيف الباطن الرائد وفي
المباراه الثانيه يلتقي الفتح مع الطائي
وتعدوا هذه المواجهه الاولى بين فريقين في
مسابقه كاس الملك وتختتم مواجهه دور 16
لمسابقه كاس الملك بالسعوديه بقمه الاتحاد
والشباب في جده
في ختام هذه النشره تذكير بابرز العالم
اوكرانيا
الجديده ضد المدعي العام وقاده في الحرس
الثوري
والاتحاد الاوروبي يصف منع النساء من
التعليم في افغانستان بجريمه ضد الانسانيه
وطالبان تتحدى الادانه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]